نعم الذي وصل الان قبل قليل هذه القطعه
العسكريه البحريه الضخمه التي تتبع للجيش
الامريكي وصلت قبل قليل الى ميناء
بورسودان هذه القطعه تحركت خلال الساعات
الماضيه في عرضه البحر الاحمر
ووصلت قبل قليل الى هذه النقطه هنا في
الميناء الشمالي تحديدا في نقطه الميناء
الاخضر بمدينه بورسودان هذه القطعه التي
تتبع للبحريه الامريكيه ستعمل على نقل نحو
300 من رعايه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الذين وصلوا يوم الامس الى مدينه بورسودان
والان تجري عمليات النقل الرعايه وبعض ذوي
الحالات او الاحتياجات الخاصه الذين
يحملون الجنسيه الامريكيه كما تشاهدون
الان في هذه الصور الحصريه والخاصه لقناه
العربيه من داخل الميناء الاخضر بمدينه
بورسودان بحضور الجيش السوداني الذي يرتب
هذه العمليه وايضا جنود يتبعون لجيش
الولايات المتحده والبحريه الامريكيه
وهيئه الموانئ البحريه ايضا التي تشرف مع
الجيش السوداني على هذه العمليه يقومون
الان بنقل وترحيل رعايه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه من ارضيه الميناء مباشره الى
هذه السفينه الضخمه التي تتبع للبحريه
الامريكيه بمعيه جنود البحريه الامريكيه
الذين وصلوا برفقه هذه القطعه البحريه
لمتابعه المزيد
من برامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات